[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مجددا مشاهدي العربيه واهلا
بكم الى اخبار الساعه مع ليلى الاختيار
ابداها بابرز العرب
مبادره السلام الصينيه اوكرانيا بانتظار
مكالمه شيء وبوتين يصفها بقاعده للتسويه
لائحه اتهام ترامب تنحي خلافات الجمهوريين
جانبا ولو مؤقتا والخوف من اعمال عنف
وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي وتشريع الكنيست
يوزيدان الطينه طينه حكومه نتنياهو بيلا
ووزير الدفاع قد يثاقم الاوضاع
الاحتجاجات الرافضه لتمرير اصلاح نظام
التقاعد قنبله موقوته قد تفجر الوضع
الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
اذا اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا على الرغم
من مئات العقوبات التي انهالت على روسيا
ورئيسها فلاديمير بوتين وملاحقتهم من قبل
المحكمه الجنائيه منذ ايام لكن هناك صديق
عزيز يصر على توطيد علاقته وهو الرئيس
الصيني تشيز الذي يزور حاليا موسكو
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله
وبما انهما صديقان عزيزان بالطبع نقاش
ملفات عديده ومنها خطه السلام التي
اعلنتها من اجل تسويه الحرب في اوكرانيا
نحو اربع ساعات ونصف قضاها الزعيماتي
مناقشه تفاصيل الخطه وتحدث عنها بوتين
اليوم المبادره الصينيه قاعده لتسويه
الوضع في اوكرانيا
نعتقد ان العديد من البنود الوارده في خطه
السلام التي قدمتها الصين تتفق مع انها
الروسي ويمكن اتخاذها كاساس لتسويه سلميه
عندما يكون الغرب وكيف مستعدين لها ومع
ذلك حتى الان لم نرى مثل هذا الاستعداد من
جانبهم
الرئيس السفه اليوم
عن بلاده
التازحي فيما يتعلق بالحرب الاوكرانيه
فيما يتعلق بمساله الازمه الاوكرانيه
التزمت الصين دائما بمقاصد ميثاق الامم
المتحده ومبادئه وبموقف موضوعي عملت بنشاط
على تعزيز السلام والمفاوضات وحددت موقفها
على اساس مزايا الموضوع نفسه لقد وقفنا
دائما بثبات الى جانب السلام والحوار والى
الجانب الصحيح من التاريخ
وعلى وقع هذه الوساطه الصينيه اتهم
المتحدث باسم الكريم الولايات المتحده
والدول الاوروبيه بالوقوف عائق امام اي
محادثات سلام بشان اوكرانيا اقل بسكوب ان
الدول الغربيه تمنع اكياد من التفكير في
المحادثات سلام محتمله
الوساطه التي تقبلها روسيا هي صينيه
الخارجيه الروسيه اعلنت اليوم ان الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا وفرنسا والمانيا لا
يمكنهم لعب دور الوسيط في عمليه السلام في
اوكرانيا كون هؤلاء مشاركين في الصراع مع
روسيا على اراضي اوكرانيا بحسب قولهم وفي
وقت سابق دعا الرئيس السابق لمؤتمر ميونخ
الى انشاء مجموعه اتصال حول اوكرانيا من
اجل اطلاق عمليه السلام والتي تضم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبريطانيا
وفرنسا والمانيا
ماذا مشاهدينا عن الجانب الاوكراني فنائبه
رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني قالت ان كياف
تنتظر معرفه ما اذا كانت ستتم مكالمه بين
الرئيس الاوكراني فولو ديلينسكي والزعيم
الصيني شي جندي وقالت صحيفه ايطاليه اليوم
بان هذه ستكون خطوه مهمه وان هناك الكثير
من الامور التي ينبغي ان يقولها او
يقولوها لبعضهم البعض على حد تعبيرها
اما الرئيس الاوكراني للبول كيف اكد انه
دعى الصين الى الحوار وينتظر ردا حيث
اشارتسكيل ان بلاده عرضت على الصين ان
تصبح شريكا في البحث عن تسويه للنزاع في
اوكرانيا
المزيد حول هذه الزياره وهذه الشراكه
الصينيه الروسيه تنضم الينا من موسكو
العربيه كاتيا ابرز ما بحث بهذه الزياره
وابرز ما توصلت اليه هذه الزياره حتى هذه
الساعه
مرحبا ليال بالفعل اليوم الثاني انتهى
اللقاءات انتهت كانت مكثفه بالنسبه لرئيس
السنيه الذي التي ابتداها طبعا مع بلقائه
مع رئيس الحكومه الروسيه بالاضافه لذلك
كان هناك اجتماعات على النطاق الموسع
والضيق بين وفدي روسيا
والصين تراساها طبعا الزعيمان الرئيس
زعيمان الصيني والروسي طبعا اهم الملفات
اولا كان على الصعيد السياسي تم بحث
الازمه الاوكرانيه وطبعا خطه الصين حول
خطه السلام الصينيه التي طرحتها منذ فتره
الذي اكد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
انها يمكن ان تكون كقاعده في المستقبل
لاجراء محادثات مع جانب الاوكراني في حال
طبعا رغبه الغرب واوكرانيا ولكن حتى الان
كما قال الرئيس الروسي بوتين انه لا يوجد
بوادر وان الغرب يحارب روسيا في اوكرانيا
حتى اخر اوكرانيا بالاضافه لذلك هناك
الملفات الاقتصاديه وهي كانت بشكل موسع تم
بحث عده محاور منها اولا توريد الطاقه
وزياده توريد الغاز الروسي الى الصين عن
طريق اطلاق خطه لبناء مشروع قوه سيبيريا
اثنان بالاضافه لذلك زياده واردات النفط
الى الصين وبناء محطه نوويه كهربائيه في
الصين بالاضافه لذلك هناك كان مشاريع
تتعلق بالمواصلات والتي تحدث عنها رئيس
الوزراء الروسي هناك مشاريع
ستطلق ايضا بين روسيا والصين فيما يخص
مواصلات في سيبيليا وفي اسيا ايضا اذا
روسيا من هذا الباب تنطلق الى الى توجه
اخر من خلال طبعا الاقتصاد في ظل العقوبات
التي تم فرضها عليها هي تعول كثيرا على
الصين كاستراتيجيه وكم وكان هناك كم كبير
من اتفاقيات التي تم توقيعها من بينها
اتفاقيه تعميق التعاون الاستراتيجي بين
روسيا
بالاضافه الى التعاون الاقتصادي التي ايضا
وقعتها اليوم هي كما يعتبرها الغرب هي
رسائل عفوا الخبراء يعتبرها هي رسائل الى
الغرب عن وجود شريك مثل الصين الى جانب
روسيا هو يؤكد التوجه نحو انشاء عالم
متعدد الاخطاب وليس احاجه وانهاء حقبه
العالم الاحادي الاخطاب كما كان منذ وقت
طويل نعم شكرا يا طعمه
من موسكو
محور صيني بوجه واشنطن
موسكو وبحسب مجله بوليتيكو صبت جام غضبها
على الغرب العام الماضي
واللغه خطابها باتت عن شيء واحد تحولها عن
الغرب واصطفافها مع الصين وايران لكن
الداخل الروسي وبحسبوليتكو ليس سعيدا
بالشريك الصيني
تحدثت عن معارضين روس تدمروا من قله
ونوعيه الدعم المقدم من الصين
المشاعر متبادله
دبلوماسيون صينيون اشاروا الى ان صبرهم
نفذ من افعال الروس في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
وفي التطورات الميدانيه تتغير المعادله
وتتغير هنا نتحدث كل ساعه على هذا النحو
بات التسيير حسابات الحرف في اوكرانيا
تقديرات اوروبيه ترجح دخول الحرب مرحله
خطيره في ظل الزياده احتياجات ثياب للصمود
وحشد الروس ل 300 الف مقاتل لشن هجوم وشي
نداءات الرئيس الاوكرانيه
الى الحلفاء باستعجال مد بلاده بالذخيره
التي واشكت على النفاذ سرعان ملاقه
استجابه واسعه اما ميدانيا مشاهدينا في
القرن اقرت موسكو بوقوع حادث استهداف شحنه
من صواريخ كروز الروسيه من طراز كاليبر
اثناء نقلها عبر السكك الحديديه في منطقه
جنكو شمال شبه جزيره القرد وفي بخموت
المعركه تحتدم اكثر اذ يتبادل الطرفان
القصف والاتهامات في محاولات لتغيير
المعادله على الارض مع تعهد كل منهما حسم
المعركه اما في دنياسك شرقي اوكرانيا
المعركه لا تقل حده عن بخموت اذ اسفل
القصف الروسيه عن مقتل مدنيين اثنين على
الاقل واصابه ثلاثه اخرين خلال الاربع
والعشرين الساعه الماضيه
في الاثناء قال مسؤولون امريكيون ان
البنتاغون يسرع عمليات تسليم دبابات ابرمز
الامريكيه الى اوكرانيا وانها اختارت
تحديث نموذج قديم لضمان سرعه التفسير هذا
وكاله واشنطن قد اعلنت في يناير انها
سترسل الدبابات بعدما اصرت لاشهر على انها
دبابات معقده للغايه ويصعب صيانتها
واصلاحها
هذا وتستعد روسيا واوكرانيا لمرحله جديده
من الصراع مع حلول فصل الربيع استعدادات
من الجانبين تهدد جهود السلام بالفشل خاصه
المساعي الصينيه والورقه التي اعدتها لوقف
القتال
[موسيقى]
اصوات البنادق والمدافع في اوكرانيا لا
تترك اي مجال لسماع نداءات الحلحله
السلميه من ربيع العام الماضي الى ربيع
العام الحالي مده زمنيه استعرت فيها نيران
الحرب اكثر فاكثر المرحله المقبله تحمل
نذر قتال ضار صحيفه
تستعد لمعركه الربيع في وقت حذر رئيس
مجموعه فاكنار من ان الجيش الاوكراني يخطط
لهجوم وشيك يهدف الى فصل قواته عن الحشد
الرئيسي للجيش الروسي الصحيفه ذاتها اكدت
ان اوكرانيا تستعد لدفع الروس بعيدا عن
مناطق سجلوا فيها انتصارات محدوده خلال
الشتاء مثل بخموت مدينه افدي افكا الواقعه
على مشارف دونيتسك في مرمى نيران القوه
الروسيه التي تسعى لبدء هجومها الربيعي
هجوم تقول كيف انه على وشك التلاشي غير ان
استخدام روسيا لصواريخها الاسرع من الصوت
اذا استمر فان اوكرانيا قد يستطيع الحفاظ
على التوازن الدقيق في تزويد الطاقه
والخدمات الاخرى ما يصعب عليها الامور
اكثر فاكثر المعاناه في الحرب لا تقتصر
على طرف دون الاخر القوه الروسيه هي
الاخرى تتكبد خسائر فادحه لانها تهاجم
مستخدمه طرقا معروفه للجيش الاوكراني
تطورات على الارض تسير عكس الجهود
المبذوله خاصه تلك التي تقوم بها الصين
دول غربيه طالبت بالضغط على بوتين للتراجع
مقابل رفض واضح من البيت الابيض لمساع
الصين جهود تصطدم بما يحدث على ارض
المعركه
فبسبب الدعم المتزايد من الغرب للقوه
الاوكرانيه خاصه من الولايات المتحده
واصرار موسكو
رفيع الصراع بلال البجدين العربيه
تتابعنا في اخبار التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
قبيله زياره رئيس رئيسه تايوان لواشنطن
مسؤول الامريكي يحذر بكين من التصعيد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد متاعب ترامب تثقل كاهله
والازمات باتت تلاحقهم من كل حد وصعب
والجنائيه اخرها على خلفيه توجيه المدعي
العام في المنهج اتهامات بشان دفع مبلغ
مليلي ممثله اباحيه عام 2016 من اجل عدم
من اجل عدم الحديث طبعا عن علاقتهما قبيل
الانتخابات الرئاسيه وقتها هذه الاتهامات
لاقت اصطفافا من حلفائه الجمهوريين اذ
يحاول حلفاء ترانسلي لمجلس النواب طلب
شهاده المدعي العام في منهات من اجل السعي
طبعا لاحباط التحرير
في الاثناء تستعد الشرطه في مدن كبرى
لاضطرابات محتمله في حال توقيف ترامب بسبب
هذا الاتهام وتكثف السلطات في نيويورك
واشنطن
والعاصمه
من وجودها تحسبا لاحتجاجات حيث قيمه
المتاريس والحواجز الفولاذيه خارج محكمه
من هاتن الجنائيه حيث يمكن توجيه الاتهام
الى
وتعليقا مشاهدينا على قضيه ترامب الاخيره
تجاوز عدد الجمهوريين الخلافات عدد منهم
الخلافات طبعا مع ترامب نائب الرئيس
السابق مايك الذي انتقلت ترامب سابقا وقف
بجانبه وقال ان الامريكيين لا يريدون رؤيه
شامبو
وانتقد قرار المدعي العام في المنهات ورغم
انه لم يقدم الدعم لكن
مكتبه لن يتدخل في تسليم التراب الى
نيويورك لكن هذا لم يمنع ديسنتس من محاوله
استغلال الازمه حيث سخر من الموقف الذي
وضع فيه ترامب نفسه
لا اعرف ما الذي يمكن ان يدفع لتقديم
اموال لنجمه اباحيه لتامين الصمت بشان نوع
من العلاقات المزعومه لا استطيع التحدث عن
ذلك ما يمكنني قوله انه اذا كان لديك مدعي
عام يتجاهل الجرائم التي تحدث كل يوم في
نطاق سلطته القضائيه واختار العوده الى
سنوات مضت لمحاوله استخدام شيء ما حول
مدفوعات الاموال التي يتم دفعها لنجوم
الافلام الاباحيه فهذا مثال على اتباع
اجنده سياسيه اعتقد ان هذا خطا جوهري
اما خصوم ترامب الديمقراطيون يتوقون
لمحاسبتهم بموجب القانون بحسب موقع اكسس
لكن البعض يخشى ان تقود هذه التهم
الجنائيه القضايا القانونيه الاكثر اهميه
المتهم فيها الرئيس السابق المشرعون في
كلا الحزبين هم الاخرين قلقون اذ حذروا من
ان يؤدي وتؤدي احتجاجات انصار ترامب الى
اندلاع اعمال عنف زياره العديد من اعضاء
الكونجرس ان شبح السادس من يناير يلوح في
الافق بينما يقوم الرئيس السابق بتحشيد
مؤيديه بنفس الطريقه من جهتها مشاهدينا
افادت وكاله بلومبر الى ان الرئيس
الامريكي السابق ضمن ترامب لن يتم تكبير
يديه اذا وجه رسميا ضده الاتهام في
نيويورك ونقلت الوكاله عن مصدر مطلع انه
على الرغم من ان ترامب سيتم اخذ بصمات
اصابعه وتصويره بشكل جانبي وامامي الا انه
لن يتم تقييد يديه امام الكاميرات
او وضعه في زنزانه مضيفا انه من المحتمل
ان يظل رهن الاحتجاز تحت حراسه جهاز سري
سيكون مكلف بالحمايه
مزيد من التفاصيل عن هذه المحاكمه ينضم
الينا من نيويورك مراسل عربيه حسين الطوب
حسين يعني ضمن التغطيات السابقه كنت تقول
حتى الساعه ليس هو معلوم اذا ما كان سيتم
توقيف ترامب ام لا هل هناك اي معطيات
قضائيه جديده من امام المحكمه
تحيه لك ليال بحسب صحيفه ديلي ميل نقلا عن
مصادر قالت انها مطلعه على القضيه فانه من
المحتمل ان يوجه الاتهام لدونالد ترامب
غدا الاربعاء ولكنه لن يحضر الى نيويورك
حتى الاسبوع المقبل الصحيفه اضافت بانه
بعد توجيه الاتهام احتمال توجيه الاتهام
سيتم التواصل بين مكتب المدعي العام وبين
جهاز الخدمه السريه الذي يحمي ترامب بعد
ذلك سيتم التنسيق بين هذين الجهازين من
اجل وضع ترتيبات لتسليم لنفسه عندما ياتي
الى نيويورك طبعا هي رجحت احتمال ان ياتي
دونالد ترامب الى نيويورك ان يسافر من
فلوريدا الى هذه الى هنا الى هذه المنطقه
وان لا يسلم نفسه هناك يستطيع فعل ذلك هذه
هي اخر المعلومات التي لدينا بهذا الشان
طبعا كما سبق وذكرنا كان هناك تجهيزات
وحشود امنيه واجراءات امنيه احترازيه
اتخذتها نيويورك تحسبا من اي اعمال شغب قد
تنتج عن قيام مؤيدين ترم بالتظاهره هنا
ولكن حتى الان هذا اليوم مره بسلامه كما
راينا وشاهدنا ولكن الشرطه نيويورك مستمره
بتواجدها بالطلب من عناصرها وضباطها بينها
يبقوا يقظين لانه ربما اذا تم توجيه
الاتهام غدا ربما يكون هناك تظاهرات غدا
ولكن الحواجز الحديديه ما زالت موجوده هنا
ايضا يوجد حضور اضافه للحضور الامنيه
المكثف هناك حضور اعلامي كبير تغطيه
اعلاميه كبيره من مختلف القنوات الامريكيه
وحتى العالميه طبعا موضوع كيف سيتم
التعامل مع ترامب هذه الاجراءات في
الحقيقه ما زالت غير واضحه مئه بالمئه
ليال لان هذه سابقه في التاريخ الامريكي
بان يتم توجيه تهم لرئيس سابق لذلك ليس من
المؤكد كما يشير او تشير معظم وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه كيف سيتم التعامل مع
ترامب بالتاكيد سيتم اخذ
[موسيقى]
دانت الخارجيه السعوديه تصريحات المسيئه
والعنصريه الصادره عن احد المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين بحق فلسطين وشعبها وفقا
لبيان صادر عن وزاره الخارجيه الخارجيه
السعوديه اكدت موقف الرياض الرافض لتلك
التصريحات كونها تنشر خطاب الكراهيه وتحرض
على العنف وتقوض محادثات السلام واكدت
المملكه على دعمها للجهود الدوليه بهدف حل
القضيه الفلسطينيه على اساس مبادره السلام
العربيه
[موسيقى]
في الاثناء مشاهدينا وصفات الخارجيه
الامريكيه تصريحات وزير ماليه اسرائيل
بشان الفلسطينيين بالخطيره بينما وصفها
وزير الخارجيه الاردني ايمن الصفدي
بالتحريضيه والعنصريه العاكسه للفكر
الاقصائي المتطرف
كما قلنا التصريحات العنصريه التحريضيه
الاستفزازيه التي اطلقها وزير في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
واطلاق هذه التصريحات على منبر يحمل خريطه
مزعومه لاسرائيل تضم الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله وتضم المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه
هذه تصريحات
ومواقف وتصرفات تحريضيه عنصريه
تعكس فكرا اقصائيا
عنصريه متطرفا اكدنا ادانته واستنكاره
ورفضه وتواصلنا مع المجتمع الدولي
لابراز خطوره مثل هذا الفكر الاقصائي
العنصريه التحريضي وانعكاساته على ليس فقط
العمليه السلميه ولكن ما يرسله من رساله
حول خطوره هذا الفكر العنصري المتطرف
وزير الماليه الاسرائيليه يبدو انه يزيد
الوضع تعقيدا بالنسبه لحكومه نتنياهو
المثقل اصلا بالمشاكل التي تواجهها قد
يفاقم وزير اخر وهنا وزير الدفاع هذه
الازمه فالقناه الثالثه عشره الاسرائيليه
قالت ان وزير الدفاع يعاب جالنت ابلغ
نتنياهو عزمه الاستقاله من منصبه اذا واصل
الائتلاف الحاكم تشريع التغييرات على جهاز
القضاء بشكل الاحادي الجانب ومن دون اجماع
واسع ونقلت القناه عن الوزير قوله ان
دعوات عصيان الاوامر العسكريه من شانها ان
تمس قدره الجيش على اداء مهامه
امر اخر مقلق هذه المره كشفت عنه اذاعه
الجيش الاسرائيلي التي افادت عبر مراسلها
السياسي بان رئيس وزراء اسرائيل
تلقى الرسائل من مسؤولين كبار في اداره
بايدن لنصحه بعدم زياره واشنطن مع اتساع
الاحتجاجات الداخليه ضد قانون تغيير
النظام القضائي وقالت اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي في تقريرها عبر تويتر ان
المسؤولين الامريكيين حذروا نتنياهو من
انه سيواجه انتقادات علنيه اذا جاء الى
البيت الابيض هذا الضغط الامريكي ربما
يبدو انه اسفر عن تغيير في خطط نتنياهو
حيث اعلنت تخفيفا لخطته الراميه الى تعديل
النظام القضائي لكن المعارضه قالت ان
الخطه لا تزال تمثل تحديا للتشريعات
الاساسيه في المحكمه العليا مما يمهد
الطريق لمواجهه دستوريه
في شان اخر يخص حكومه نتنياهو ايضا ابدت
الخارجيه الامريكيه انزعاجها الشديد من
الغاء الكنيسه اعاده المستوطنات شمال
الضفه مؤكده ان التشريع استفزازي وينتهك
الوعود وكانت الكنيسه الاسرائيليه كان قد
صادق اليوم على قانون اقره عام 2005 ويمنح
للاسرائيليين حق العوده الى مستوطنات
سابقه تم اخلائها في شمال الضفه الغربيه
من حيث ينضم الينا يؤاف شاطرين المحلل
السياسي استاذ يو اف سابدا من موضوع يعني
التحذيرات الامريكيه الانتقادات تتسع
وتكبر لينه ياهو لحكومته من المعلوم بان
القيم الديمقراطيه هي اساس العلاقه بين
واشنطن وبين اسرائيل وبان النموذج
الديمقراطي الذي يعني ارسلته اسرائيل هو
تعبير عن النموذج الامريكي اليوم يعني
تدمير هذا النموذج كما يفعل نتنياهو الى
اي مدى سيضر بالعلاقه بين الطرفين
احنا نرى ان هناك توتر بالعلاقات ما بين
حكومه اسرائيل والاداره الامريكيه هذا
توتر بات جليا بعد الدخول
نتنياهو الى المنزل
لم تتم دعوه للبيت الابيض كما كان متوقعا
وهذا توتر مستمر هناك تحذيرات امريكيه على
طول الخط من كل الكبر المسؤولين التي
الذين زاروا اسرائيل
وهذه تحديدات كما نسمع مستمره بالفعل
ما تقوم به حكومه يعتبر في واشنطن خرج
للاسس الديمقراطيه مع انه الديمقراطيه في
اسرائيل مختلفه نوعا ما عنا الديمقراطيه
في الولايات المتحده هكذا كان دائما
واليوم نتنياهو يقوم بخطوه التي فيها
يعني
نقاط تشابه مع ما يحدث الولايات المتحده
ولكن النظام الديمقراطي ككل في اسرائيل
مختلف تماما وما يقوم به في هذا الاطار
معناه تضمير الديمقراطيه في اسرائيل
البوادر الانقسام الداخلي داخل يعني حكومه
نتنياهو بعدما سمعناه عن وزير الدفاع الى
اي مدى سيضعف موقف نتنياهو وماذا عن بوادر
الازمه الدستوريه مع رفض نتنياهو لجوء
المعارضه الى ما يعرف بالمحكمه العليا
طبعا الاعتراض على التعديلات
نعم حتى الان المعارضه ترفض اي تواصل مع
الائتلاف الحاكم بشان هذه التعديلات التي
مزمع اجراؤها في الجهاز القضائي المعارضه
تقول انه لا يمكن في ظل ما يحدث من عمليات
سن القوانين ان تتم هناك يتم هناك حوار
المفاوضات حول كل هذه النقاط هذا يضعف فقط
المعارضه لانه الائتلاف الحاكم قد يعمل ما
يشاء فيما بعد لهذا السبب
سمعنا اليوم
نتنازل نوعا ما من قبل
الذي اعلن هذا المساء بان هناك
نيه لوقف سن القوانين خلال عيد الفسح
المجيد لدى الشعب اليهودي
اذن فسح
سياتي بعد كم من اسبوع بعد اسبوعين الان
في هذه الفتره لا اعتقد استبعد ان تكون
هناك مفاوضات حقيقيه وبعد ذلك يجب على ان
يقرر اما انا
الاستمرار في عمليه سن هذه القوانين
تعميق للازمه يا اما وقفها تعميق الازمه
داخليا وتعميق الازمه خارجيا يعني اليوم
مع القرار قرار الغاء الكنيسه اعاده
المستوطنات لشمال الضفه يعني اليوم
نتنياهو يساعد داخليا وخارجنا الى اي مدى
التصعدين سيضرن به وهل يمكن ان نرى تصعيد
يعني على الارض بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين مع الدخول شهر رمضان
المبارك خصوصا ان هناك تخوفات بهذا الخصوص
كل تاكيد والاجواء متوتره جدا خصوصا في ظل
التصريحات والخطوات التي تقوم به حكومه
بها حكومه اسرائيل بما في ذلك
تعديل القانون اليوم حاليا يسمح
للاسرائيليين العوده لزياره الى
المستوطنات التي تم اخلاها في الشمال
الضفه الغربيه اعتقد ان حكومه نتنياهو
جهات فيها على الاقل معنيه بان يكون هناك
احتكاك اكثر مع طرف الفلسطيني هي وسمعنا
تصريحات يعني يقول انه ليس هناك شعب
فلسطيني هذا هو الموقف الحقيقي
لهذه الفئات هم لا يعترفون اصلا بان هناك
شعب فلسطيني واعتقد انه في شهر رمضان
المبارك للاسف الشديد الاجواء ستكون
متوتره جدا عيد الفسح لدى الشعب اليهودي
يصادف شهر رمضان هذه المره اعتقد انه قد
ننزلك الى العنف للاسف الشديد في الاسابيع
المقبله
وساعتها سيكون الضغط على نت
ياسي حدثنا من حيث
[موسيقى]
فيما يتوقع ان تحل رئيسه تايوان ساي
انجوين ضيفه على الولايات المتحده نهايه
الشهر الجاري حذر مسؤول امريكيه رفيع
الصين من التصعيد اتاكد ان واشنطن لا ترى
اي مبرر لان تستخدم بكين هذه الزياره
كزاريعه من اجل تكثيف اي نشاط عدواني حول
مضيق تايوان كما اوضح المسؤول ان الاداره
الامريكيه تطالب الصين بابقاء قنوات
الاتصالات رفيعه المستوى مفتوحه بحسب نقلت
رويتروس وفي السياق اعتبر المسؤول انه لا
شيء جديد في زياره سعي وانها لا تختلف
طبعا عن زيارات سابقه جرت وبالتالي لا يجب
تحميل هذه الزياره اكثر مما تحملهم على
الجهه الاخرى مشاهدينا نددت وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه بتلك الزياره مؤكده
رفضها لها تحت اي مسمى او عنوان
توترات بين بكين و واشنطن بلغت اعلى
مستوياتها منذ سنوات اما السبب فالدعم
الامريكي لتايوان ففي اغسطس 2022 اجرى
الجيش الصيني مناورات عسكريه ضخمه ردا على
زياره رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي لتايوان
كما ارسلت الصين سفنا وطائرات بانتظام عبر
خط الوسط
واطلقت صواريخ فوق تايوان سقطت في المنطقه
الاقتصاديه الخالصه لليابان
من جهتها تايوان ساعه الى الطلب من واشنطن
زياده دعمها العسكري لتوافق واشنطن على
بيعها اسلحه من هذا خيره لطائرات مقاتله
من طراز اف 16
[موسيقى]
تواجه منصه تيك توك اتهامات بالتجسس ونشر
محتوى مسيء وما جعل المطالب بحظر التطبيق
في دول كثيره تتزايد خاصه في الولايات
المتحده بل ووصلت حد مخاططه فالنت
تيك توك حكايه تطبيق للمقاطع المصوره
تتحول الى مصدر جدل دولي عابر للقارات
منصه اطلقت من الصين عام 2016 لتنتشر
كالنار في الهشيم خاصه في هواتف المراهقين
عبر كل الاسقع حرب عالميه على تيك توك من
الولايات المتحده الى اوروبا تضاعفت حده
الانتقادات بل الاجراءات عدد متزايد من
المشرعين الامريكيين يسعون الى حظر
التطبيق بسبب مخاوف تتعلق بالامن القومي
واشنطن تكشف عن تتبع التطبيق لعشرات
المواقع الحكوميه ما يعني التجسس صحيفه
وولد جورنال كشفت ما هو اخطر تقرير لشركه
الامن السيبراني قال ان اكثر من 20 موقعا
حكوميا في الولايات المتحده يحتوي على
شفره تتبع الويب والتي اعدتها بايت دانس
الشركه الام للتيك توك الرئيس التنفيذي
لتيك توك شوزيو
وقال ان الشركه تواجه لحظه فارقه ومحوريه
التطبيق يضم الان اكثر من 150 مليون
مستخدم نشط شهريا في الولايات المتحده اي
ما يقرب من نصف عدد السكان
المصائب لا تاتي فرادى بعد واشنطن روما
تفتح تحقيقا في انتهاك التيك توك قواعد
النشر اما اوسلو فقد نصحت موظفيها بعدم
تحميل التطبيق المنصه الصينيه الشهيره
مهدده في كل مكان
المخاطر تصل حد مقاضاتها في ايطاليا بسبب
مضمونها الذي يختلف عما يبث داخل الصين
وخارجها
الاتهامات تتراوح بين نشر محتوى سيء يشجع
على سوء التغذيه والترويج للانتحار
والتاثير على القاصرين ايضا هي تفاعلات ما
تزال مستمره في انتظار مستقبل التطبيق
المثير للجدل بلال البجدين العربيه
تابعونا في اخبار الساعه مشاهدينا ولكن
بعد قليل في افغانستان عام دراسي جديد
فتحت ابوابه للجميع من قبل طالبان الا
الطالبات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في فرنسا اتهمت
زعيمه اليمين مارين رئيس امانويل بدفع
البلاد الى حافه انفجار اجتماعيه بسبب
اصلاحه المتعلق بنظام المعاشات التقاعديه
وقالت في مقابله مع وكاله ان الحكومه تهيئ
كل الظروف الانفجار اجتماعي وكانهم يبحثون
عن ذلك
قنبله موقوته قد تنفجر في اي لحظه لتدمر
معها مؤسسات الجمهوريه الخامسه في فرنسا
ان توصلت الاحتجاجات الرافضه لتمرير اصلاح
نظام التقاعد المعارضه اكدت استمرارها في
اتباع كل الطرق لاسقاط قانون التقاعد ومعه
الحكومه بعد ان اخفق نوابها في الجمعيه
الوطنيه الفرنسيه في حجب الثقه عن حكومه
اليزابيث حيث اعلن رئيس الجمعيه الوطنيه
البراون بفيت عن فشلها
الاغلبيه المطلوبه للتصويت بحجم الثقه هي
287 بما انه لم يتم الوصول الى الاغلبيه
المطلوبه فلم يتم اعتماد اقتراح سحب الثقه
اما المحاميه من حزب فرنسا الابيه فوصفت
الحكومه بالميته احتجنا فقط الى تسعه
اصوات لحجب الثقه وكسر هذه الحكومه
واصلاحها الحكومه ميته بالفعل في الشعب
الفرنسي ولم تعد تتمتع بالشرعيه اتهامات
بالبؤس المعنوي والسياسي وعدم امتلاك
الشرعيه الشعبيه ولا النيابيه يواجهها
الرئيس الفرنسي الذي بات مستقبله على
المحاك اتهامات قد تدخل البلاد في ازمه
حكم هي الاولى في تاريخ فرنسا
مارلو فان زعيمه اقصى اليسار كان لها راي
اخر حيث اتهمت الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون
بالفشل الذريع وبان سياسته ستساهم في
تمزيق الدوله الفرنسيه
صحيفه لوبينيون محسوبه على الليبراليين في
فرنسا اكدتنا الازمه قد تتفاقم والحكومه
ستتعرض لخسائر كبيره وهي تخوض معركه اصلاح
نظام التقاعد اما صحيفه المحسوبه على اقصى
اليسار فاشارت الى وضع لا يحتمل وحاله من
الانهيار في قواعد الحكومه الفرنسيه
مراقبون
للتطورات الحاصله اكدوا ان استعمال منطق
القوه في تمرير قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد
سيؤدي لاغراق البلاد في المزيد من الفوضى
[موسيقى]
وفي افغانستان اعيد فتح المدارس للعام
الدراسي الجديد ولكن بدون فصول دراسيه حيث
باتت المدارس خاليه من التلاميذ او
بالاحرى من التلميذات بسبب القيود التي
تفرضها طالبان على تعليمهم
[موسيقى]
من جهاتها طلبت الامم المتحده حركه طالبان
في افغانستان بالتراجع عن المنع التي
فرضته على تعليم المراه مجموعه خبراء من
الامم المتحده اكدنا ان طالبا ليس لديها
اي مبرر لانكار حق المراه في التعذيب كما
اضافوا ان افغانستان طرف في معاهدات الامم
المتحده لحقوق الانسان وهي ملزمه بحمايه
حقوق المراه في التعليم كما عبرت الامم
المتحده عن مخاوفها حول جوده التعليم كون
طالبان استبدلت المعلمين المحترفين في
المدارس وغيرت المناهج الدراسيه
[موسيقى]
في حفل في الرياض احتفت قناه العربيه
بمرور 20 عام على تاسيسها حيث اكد
القائمون على المحطه مواصله العمل للحفاظ
على موقع العربيه الرائد في فضاء الاعلام
العربي
[موسيقى]
في الرياض احتفلت العربيه بعيد تاسيسها
العشرين في مارس 2003 انطلقت من مجموعه ام
بي سي وبعد ذلك التاريخ بعقدين لا تزال
رقما اساسيا في فضاء الاعلام العربي
بحضور لافت من وزراء سعوديين وعدد من
الاعلاميين والفنانين
استعرض رئيس مجلس اداره مجموعه ام بي سي
الشيخ وليد الابراهيم الهدف وراء تاسيس
العربيه وما انجزته في 20 عاما
ولدت العربيه من غرفه اخبار ام بي سي
لتكون المتخصصه والشامله في مجالها
ومنذ البدء
كانت مشروعا وطنيا سعوديا
بعد ان ظهرت القنوات الفضائيه الاخباريه
الناطقه بالعربيه
والتي سعى بعضها
لتوجيه الراي العام
وفقا لاجندات معينه
كانت في اغلب الاحداث تتخذ مواقف سلبيه من
المملكه ومن دول الخليج
طريق نجاح العربيه لم يكن سهلا ابدا
فارواح فقدت في سبيل الوفاء بوعد المحطه
ان تعرف اكثر كما
ركز سام بارنت الرئيس التنفيذي لام بي سي
في كلمته اما
يجدر بي ان اسلط الضوء على 18 شخصا فقدوا
حياتهم في سبيل خدمه قناتنا في السنوات
العشرين الماضيه ويجب ان لا ننسى مطلقا
المخاطر التي تواجهها طواقمنا والتضحيات
التي يقدمها الكثير من الصحفيين والثمن
الذي دفعته العربيه نفتخر بهم جميعا ونحن
ملتزمون بمواصله عملهم بذات المستوى من
النزاهه على مدار العشرين عاما القادمه
في اشاره على ما يبدو في بدايه طريقها
اختارت العربيه ان يكون نهجها هو المهنيه
بعيدا عن الشعبويه والدعايه
وكانت عنصرا في معركه التنوير بعيدا عن
العنف والجهل كما يقول ممدوح المهيني
المدير العام لقناتي العربيه والحدث
العربيه لم تركن ابدا لتاريخها الطويل ففي
عيدها العشرين تعلن عن مزيد من التوسع
باطلاق اذاعه العربيه اف ام نعم انا مدير
محظوظ
لانني معكم في الرياض عاصمه المستقبل
وقبله المؤسسات العالميه الكبرى حيث تبث
العربيه نشراتها وبرامجها من استديوهاتها
وتستمر في توسعها
والياذن لمعالي وزير الاعلام وسعاده رئيس
مجلس الاداره
بالاعلان من هنا من الرياض باطلاق اذاعه
العربيه اف ام
[تصفيق]
لتكون الاقرب دوما والاقدر على استجابات
والاقدر على الاستجابه الاحتياجات الجمهور
المختلفه في احتفاليه عيد العربيه العشرين
ينظر مدير المؤسسه بعين الى ماض مشرف
وبعين اخرى الى مستقبل تسعى خلاله العربيه
الى الحفاظ على موقعها في مقدمه فضاء شديد
التنافسيه
[موسيقى]
شكرا لكم محمد اعلنا المحكمه العليا في
السعوديه ان الخميس هو اول ايام شهر رمضان
المبارك لهذا العام وذلك بعدما تعذر رؤيه
هلال شهر رمضان في المرصدين وبعدما دعت
المحكمه العليا في السعوديه بوقت سابق الى
تحري رؤيه هلال شهر رمضان اليوم وبهذا
الاعلان يكون يوم غد الاربعاء هو المتمم
لشهر شعبان على ان يكون الخميس هو اول
ايام شهر رمضان لهذا العام
نختم ما اخبار الساعه مشاهدينا من مسلسل
تدلاسو الذي كان العام الماضي اكثر مسلسل
كوميديه يحصد جوائز الاميره عاد تدلسوا من
جديد قبل ايام بموسم ثالث واداره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن حاولت استغلال نجاح
المسلسل الشهير وتاثر به طبعا الامريكيين
والعالم كله بابطاله ليوجه لطقامه الدعوه
زياره البيت الابيض والهدف نبيل التوعيه
بالصحه العقليه
انه لشرف عظيم ان ازور البيت الابيض وان
تتاح لي الفرصه للتحدث الى الرئيس جو
بايدن والسيده الاولى حول اهميه الصحه
العقليه لذا بغض النظر عن هويتك وعن
المكان الذي تعيش فيه وعما صوتت له فمن
المحتمل اننا جميعا صادفنا شخصا كان يعاني
ويشعر بالعزله والوحده والقلق وقد نكون
هنا نتحدث عن انفسنا ايضا
في ختام اخبار الساعه مشاهدي
مبادره السلام الصينيه اوكرانيا بانتظار
مكالمه تشي وبوتين يصفها بقاعده للتسويه
لائحه اتهام ترامب تنحي خلافات الجمهوريه
جانبا ولو مؤقتا والخوف من اعمال عنف
وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي وتشريع الكنيست
يزيدان طين حكومه نتنياهو بيلا ووزير
الدفاع قد يفاقم الاوضاع
الاحتجاجات الرافضه لتمرير اصلاح نظام
التقاعد قنبله موقوته قد تفجر الوضع
الاجتماعي
[تصفيق]
المزيد مشاهدينا عبر مواقع العربيه الى
هنا اتي الى ختام اخبار الساعه شكرا
للمتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]